Animals don’t set out to teach us anything
at all – but we all have a lot to learn
from our interactions with them nevertheless.
Imagine that we come back from work unusually
late. It’s been a tricky day: a threatened
resignation, an enraged supplier, a lost document,
two delayed trains… But none of the mayhem
is of any concern to one friend waiting by
the door uncomplicatedly pleased to see us:
Pippi, a two-year-old Border Terrier with
a continuous appetite for catching a deflated
football in her jaws. She wants to play in
the usual way, even if it’s past nine o’clock
now, with us in the chair and her sliding
around the kitchen, and, unexpectedly, so
do we. We’re not offended by her lack of
overall interest in us. It’s at the root
of our delight. Here, at last, is someone
wholly indifferent to almost everything about
us except for our dexterity at ball-throwing,
someone who doesn’t care about the Brussels
meeting, who will forgive us for not warning
the finance department in time about the tax
rebates and for whom the Lisbon conference
is beyond imagining. One of the most consoling
aspects of animals – it might be a dog,
a sheep, a lizard or a beetle – is that
their priorities have nothing whatsoever to
do with our own perilous and tortured agendas.
They are redemptively unconcerned with everything
we are and want. They implicitly mock our
self-importance and absorption and so return
us to a fairer, more modest sense of our role
on the planet. A sheep doesn’t know about
our feelings of jealousy, it has no interest
in our humiliation and bitterness around a
colleague; it has never emailed. On a walk
in the hills, it simply ambles towards the
path we’re on and looks curiously at us,
then takes a lazy mouthful of grass, chewing
from the side of his mouth as though it were
gum.
Ducks nibble
at the weeds, waddle down to the water and
paddle about in circles without any interest
in which century it happens to be from a human
point of view; they’ve never heard of the
economy; they don’t know what country they
live in; they don’t have new ideas or regret
what happened yesterday. They don’t care
about the career hurdles or relationship status
of the person who sprinkles a few bread crumbs
near them. Time around animals invites us
into a world in which most of the things that
obsess us have no significance – which corrects
our characteristic over-investment in matters
which make only a limited contribution to
the essential task of existence: to be kind,
to make the most of our talents, to love and
to appreciate.
we believe in making the world a more emotinally intelligent place.  To that end we have also produced some extra ordinary books.
As well as other merchandise that re-enforces some of the themes illustraited in our videos.
Please click on the link below to see more.